you guys have probably heard of the term
red pilling and you know it's becoming
more and more common today you've even
seen guys like Elon Musk use it on you
know Twitter at some point but what does
it mean to you so that you know for the
folks that maybe haven't heard it can
you define that for us to to the best of
your ability it's unplugging from
society's lies you know culture Society
religion education marketing Hollywood
they sell you a bill of sales it's
simply not true like at some point guys
come to the realization that uh you know
what they were told and I'll use one
simple example so something like
marriage you know for example any guy
that's been through the divorce machine
understands that women aren't
necessarily sugar and spice and all
things nice and that if you take your
vows and you know promise to be uh
together forever with one another in
sickness and health and uh uh you know
rich or poor and all that sort of stuff
at some point guys or 50 of the guys
will go through the divorce grinder and
they'll learn well that's not entirely
true and women do care about your
success and if you stop chasing
Excellence then she might stop looking
at you as the apple of her eye sort of
thing so so that's what a that's what a
red pilling moment is and I think it's
from The Matrix right it was it was like
a matrix yeah yeah it's like one of
those things that like the underground
Community sort of pulled from The Matrix
and they made it their own lingle like
red pill blue pill sort of thing and I
think there was three events that sort
of red pilled me that led up to the book
The unplugged Alpha and and the first
one was me going through my own divorce
roughly three years after my marriage uh
then it was a lobbying effort that I
dealt with in Ontario here in Canada
because there was legislation that
credit card companies of banks uh pushed
through to essentially eliminate the
debt negotiate debt negotiation industry
and then the third thing was after I got
divorced I got tied up with a uh with a
woman that was also Divorced with a
couple kids in Toad and a lot of the
things that I thought you know my entire
life just kept getting beaten down it's
like okay she's violated that you know
you know she's betrayed me here and
there sort of thing it's like one thing
after another you have to come to the
realization and and stop pointing the
finger at other people and blame
yourself for the results that you get
and the book itself is really just a
collection of of some life experiences
that I went through where I made my
wounds my work so what mistakes were you
making because you it sounds like if I'm
hearing you correctly you you attracted
and I don't want to miss stay here but
it sounded like you said you attracted
two of the wrong uh Partners right is
that correct
um yeah so that's actually a a very good
place to start so definitely chose the
wrong wife yeah okay uh not a bad woman
just not a good woman for me and you're
owning that absolutely 100 yeah
um you know same thing with the lady
that I dated after I got divorced okay
um
no they're like like guys make
incredibly bad choices when it comes to
relationships and that's one of the
things my book deals with a lot and to
help sort of get guys heads squared away
properly
um it's one of the reasons why a lot of
my coaching comes from some some very
high net worth individuals that have
either dealt with problem women in their
lives they're very successful in
business like one of the things I've
noticed about entrepreneurs is you can
be a weapon in your business build
something that's phenomenal generate
huge huge amounts of Revenue hire lots
of people solve big problems in the
world but suck in their personal life
like allow an absolute disaster to run
them right
um so these are the sorts of things that
I help guys with you know getting their
heads squared away with
I think it's uh it's also interesting
because you hear a lot about there's
like the the gender gap and this this
male dominance over society and all
these things and I've heard some you
know recent uh discussions on this where
the the wealth regardless of male or
female is probably concentrated to the
very top and a lot of the the things
that guys are going through every day
like we we have a property management
company right and these guys are out
there grinding and doing some very
challenging work throughout the day so
it's it's interesting to see how this
thing is morphed into okay there's
probably some Bad actors out there that
are doing some you know negative things
but also a lot of guys are getting up at
4am in the morning going out doing the
[ __ ] work that no one else wants to do
and we're saying that guy is privileged
meanwhile he's out there humping it you
know and the work I'm saying like he's
out there humping the job to provide for
his family and do the right thing and I
just don't see how the that is that is
living this this life of uh of privilege
and and dominance it's it's almost you
know a life of service to me and that
that's the thing where I think we're
getting crossed up these days yeah there
was a male feminist his name's Dr Warren
Farrell that I think lobbied for close
to 15 to 20 years for women's rights uh
was the only male member elected to a
board of a feminist organization and I
think he realized if I'm not mistaken
about halfway into his career that men
are aren't actually the privileged sex
uh it's it's women that are privileged
and women that are protected
um and it's kind of been all that way
you know and I'm good with that as a man
and that's probably sexist to say like I
don't know what's okay it is but like
you don't want to be the man like I want
to protect provide but I also want to
preside too the problem in today's world
is guys still have responsibility to
family and their wife but they don't
have any Authority and when you're in a
position where you have responsibility
without any Authority then that's a
position of slavery
um yeah that's wow that's very well
articulated yeah and fantastic that's
how we got there is you know just
something that took several decades of
um I think Society softening men
becoming weaker at testosterone levels
lowering uh women being sold this bill
of goods by toxic feminism where they've
been told that you know you don't need
no man or you need a man like a fish
needs bicycle sort of thing and uh
they've been told to put off having
families getting married finding a top
shelf sort of virtuous guy and you know
contributing to family and Society in
that way in their 20s and now you have a
very very large contingent of women in
their late 30s or even 40s uh you know
you see them out there on dating sites
where they're looking for their equal
where they've got their three or four
degrees they're framed and mahogany on
their wall they make great money well
into six figures and they just can't
find a guy that wants to be with them
but what they've done is they've created
themselves they basically turn
themselves into men you know they went
and looked at what they thought was
attractive and because toxic feminism
sold them that lie that you have to go
and do all these things then they come
to the realization at some point where
they hit this wall and they're like wow
guys don't want me or I'm having a hard
time finding a guy that I can see but
look at the numbers I've also seen
statistics that say that the guy's over
30 who are not married that are you know
over 5 10 or 5 11 or something like that
it's like
maybe a quarter of one percent or
something you're literally trying to
find something that doesn't exist at
that point in your life so yeah it's
really impossible they have this overly
entitled sense of uh worth where they
think that there's like there's this
coin This this term that was coined
remember I was at this dinner party once
about 10 or 15 years ago I was single at
the time and one of the guys wives you
know said to me like why are you single
rich like you got the six sixes and I
said to her well what's that I'd never
heard of that wait you said six sixes
six sixes yeah and I can't wait for this
I have no idea oh yeah it's coming okay
so the six six is as you know as the
gals portrayed and I think these women
they were probably early 40s at the time
um you know the typical gals you know
the wine glasses and their hair and a
makeup all done with a couple of guys
sitting around in the corner and the
guys are going on about happy wife happy
life sort of thing and the six sixes
were purportedly uh six feet tall 600
horsepower cars 600 uh sorry 600
horsepower cars six figure income
six-pack abs six inches in the pants and
I think the last one was
um
uh six months out of a relationship
right so it's the last one's hard to
find yeah well look I mean here's the
thing like even if you use a six foot
tall metric and we know that women are
looking for taller guys I mean like even
if you know you look at dating apps they
almost always explicitly stay looking
for a tall guy or must be over six foot
in some cases even six foot two if you
Google the stats the the amount of men
in North America that are over six foot
two is less than I think four percent
the amount of men that are over six foot
I think is less than something like 15
the average height for a guy today is
about five foot eight five foot nine so
when the vast majority of the female
population sets that very high standard
and then you set it set aside the other
five sixes which seem to be very
important to them as well you start
running into problems where there's all
these Single Ladies today right so
there's so there's a lot of very complex
issues sort of intermingling and
colliding in the sexual Marketplace
today when it comes to relationships and
love I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out